how pretty you look how pretty oh
actually it handles closes pretty well
but
push part
oh that's not pee streaming gear is what
every other company is churning out
these days whether it's crafting out
Fresh Products like in highest USB
profile streaming microphone or
revamping an existing product like what
Audio Technica has done with the ath
m50x STS by slapping a mic onto an m50x
that we'll be taking out for a spin
today by now a lot of you should know
about Auto technicals m50x headphones
they're one of the most widely used pair
of cans throughout a ton of Industries
And Trades from music production
podcasts live audio mixing and shows and
streaming I've been playing around with
this for a while to edit this video and
other videos but more importantly having
a great time with proximity chat in
battlebot using this mic
foreign
we'll get into my thoughts later on
before you even get the box for the ath
m50x STS dream set you're faced with a
choice between the USB a with USBC
adapter or one with XLR with a quarter
inch adapter version digital and analog
versions basically we have the USB
version so the box has an extra pair of
nylon pads with the leather ones on the
headphones a USBC adapter and the
headphones and from this point of the
video I'll be swapping over from the
rode Wireless go-to Max that we usually
use to the ath m50x STS so with the
headphones on I have to say you know
they sound great and nothing much has
changed audio Wise from the original
m50x and as for the ear pads you can
choose between the classic nylon which
I'm using right now all the new leather
pads which are here I grew up with all
the technical headphones and the nylon
pads have always served me well with the
occasional replacement every now and
then because they flicked and peeled
quite a bit but I will say 29 year old
so the verdict on this new leather pads
they are super comfortable let's talk
about why there are two versions I'm
pretty sure the reason for spitting them
between USB and XLR has more to do with
USB having the software for the
headphones and microphone while the XLR
version is analog that would sort of
justify the stock price differences but
besides that I'm of the opinion that
auto Technica really should have just
released it all as a set so you can swap
out the cables as and when it's required
and that's pretty much the opinion of
many people out there so maybe all the
technical can do something about that in
the next iteration of the stream sets
besides that moving on to the rest of
the headphones the headband is a pretty
comfy padded leather you can adjust the
length of the cans to better fit our
Noggin the microphone only becomes
active when you swing it down all the
way one thing to note if you want to
mute the microphone for a moment just
take note that when you're sliding it up
the microphone will pick up that action
so here this
and now the audio is coming from the
Nikon z62 that we have over there and
now I'm bringing it back down and now
we're back to the audio technical mptx
STS and lastly there is a rocker slash
button on the left side of the
headphones to control monitoring side
tool you can adjust the volume with the
rocker and press it in to turn
monitoring or side tone on and off the
cardioid condenser microphone is the
main thing I'm concerned with in this
whole setup other technical has going on
I have to say it's pretty sturdy with
this bendy bit being metal and it feels
premium how does it sound honestly I
mean you can hear it for yourself it
sounds pretty damn solid the r model
after the 20 series anyway it's pretty
well balanced the only thing is that it
doesn't filter out background noise as
much unfortunately but then again that's
also a good thing the downside obviously
being you'll have unwanted noise the
upside being you'll pick up anything
meme or content worthy while still
sounding decent if you really think
about it it's one thing to not have a
way to filter our noise and it's a whole
other thing to filter out noise but
sound
like so I'm still picking the
former no competition Clarity is what
you want so even if this thing doesn't
do the job of you know filter or noise
and everything in the background
it still makes you sound damn good and
that's what I want also this is how it
sounds like as I turn the mic so now the
mic is facing me and I'm turning it this
way and now I'm behind the microphone
and here it is down here like that and
now we're back to the front of the
microphone and I'm going to be putting
the microphone on so this is what your
audience will hear when you're putting
your headphones back on and your
microphone is still turned on so now we
are going to be doing a couple more real
world tasks to give you a better idea
before we get into that though this
channel is supported by Brands who help
us improve our content and keep us going
so stay around for the sponsored message
meet the Cyber 15 gaming laptop from MSI
check out this translucent material
design that only looks good but feels
good thanks to its Ultra lightweight
chassis at only 1.98 kilograms give
yourself the upper Edge in gaming with
its blazing fast performance powered by
the latest 12-gen Intel Core i7 HD
series processor and Nvidia RTX 4000
series gpus and stay immersed with its
the hibic twin speaker sound system that
provides an auditory Feast like no other
for more details check out msi.com so
this is how the micro sound like when
you are in a gaming type situation
so this is basically how it sounds like
when you're talking over and playing
games at the same time
this is how you will sound like over
Discord to your friends colleagues and
channel members when you're using the
auto technical m50x STS USB headphones
so this is how you sound like on the
other end of a Google meets call to your
friends and colleagues the reason why
we're doing these tasks on Discord and
Google meets is because you know
different apps have different audio
requirements and audio settings so you
have an even clearer picture now of how
you will sound like when you get one of
these
are you music streamers out there
basically this is how it's going to
sound like when you have your guitar
[Music]
strumming
we're gonna play the theme song for a
consistency
let's talk about the oldest
let's talk about your friends
let's talk about the summer
and how you wish it would
did I forget to tell you
how pretty you look how pretty oh
actually it handles pulses pretty well
but
push part
oh that's not pee
it's a oh my God here is the thing if
you're looking for a streaming setup
without the hassle you get these if
you're looking for a brand new gaming
headset that's tried true and tested the
heck you get these it's one thing to
have a cool looking setup with a
microphone on this and kitty earphones
that and RGB that will cure the
colorblind it's a whole other thing to
have a functional setup if you take the
cause of that fancy microphone with the
arm the headphones and a bit extra for
the kitty ears you could get everything
in this and on top of that they are very
comfy I had them on for three hours
straight without feeling like my head
was going to explode so it's safe to say
that these are some of the best
headphones I have used thus far the
things I wish the headphones had are
volume control and the option to swap
between the USB XLR and quarter inch
options instead of having to pick and
choose you know kind of swap out the
wires it would probably mean paying more
but at the same time I get that not
everyone will be getting an audio
interface and will stick to the USB as
the most viable option for first-time
streamers especially or people that want
a more streamlined setup without
compromising on quality either set costs
us 199 according to their Us site at the
time of recording however on the
Singaporean front from Singapore if you
didn't know we are looking at 278
dollars for the XLR set and 318 for the
USB set it's regional reasons I believe
that may sound like a lot but if you
combine the pricing of the cheapest 20
Series Microphone off the website with a
pair of athftx headphones the m50x STS
headphones is actually a pretty damn
good deal because it's still relatively
cheaper than buying the two separately I
still feel that it's Justified with
other technical quality with user
experience
just need to try these for yourselves
the ath m50x STS is solid audio
engineering and tell would be a
benchmark for me moving forward but the
real question is would you get it
yourself what do you really look for in
a pair of streaming or gaming headphones
leave your answers and any questions you
have about the ath and 50x STS USB
version in the comment section below
don't forget to follow us on all about
socials right here to keep up to date
with everything we put out on all the
fronts right here and if you liked this
video make sure to like And subscribe to
our channel for more it goes a long way
if you want to see more stuff check this
out
foreign
[Music]